Raúl ya tenemos a Argentina y a Brasil
en octavos de final no pudo ser para
Argentina pero hoy podemos soñar porque
no con la clasificación de una tercera
selección latinoamericana para los
octavos de final de esta copa mundo de
Qatar 2022 hablamos de Costa Rica que se
mide en la tercera fase en la tercera
fase del grupo E contra Alemania los
ticos que saben que con una victoria
estarán en la siguiente instancia de
esta copa mundo dijo el profesor Luis
Fernando Suárez el seleccionador de
Costa Rica podemos soñar con volver a
dar la sorpresa como hicieron ya contra
Japón al ganarle por la mínima a Los
japoneses que venían en ese entonces de
ganar a Alemania Se presume que habrá
cambios en este once inicial para este
partido crucial de los costarricenses
para Alemania Por otra parte le sirve
solamente ganar y esperar a lo que
ocurra en el otro partido de este grupo
es en el que Japón se enfrenta contra
España los españoles que con un empate
estarán ya en la próxima fase de este
mundial incluso también le sirve una
derrota partido histórico es el Costa
Rica Alemania por primera vez una mujer
Estefanía capaj de Francia estará
dirigiendo este encuentro como árbitra
lo hará acompañada además de dos
latinoamericanas de neusa la brasileña y
de Karen Díaz la mexicana como líneas
Tenemos también actividad en el grupo f
en el que Canadá ya eliminada se mide
contra Marruecos Marruecos quiere ser la
primera selección árabe de este mundial
que supera la fase de grupos no lo pudo
hacer Arabia Saudita que jugaba aquí
como local después de haber caído ayer
contra México los marroquíes que se
aferran al buen fútbol que están
demostrando que se aferran a su estrella
silla para volver a unos octavos de
final por primera vez desde
1986 en el otro partido de este grupo La
Croacia de Luka modric se mide contra la
Bélgica de Kevin acrobacia que le vale
solamente un empate Para volver a
meterse en los octavos de final a
Bélgica que solamente le sirve ganar
para mantenerse con vida aquí en